22nd of april
2021 we're sitting today under the
licensing act
2003 to hear an application made under
the act my name is councillor maddie
thompson and i have been appointed
chairman for the meeting
i have some chairman's notices this
meeting is held under regulations which
came into effect on the fourth of april
in response to the code 19 situation
and there are just a few housekeeping
rules to run through
first of all please could i ask everyone
present in the meeting to ensure your
microphone remains muted when not
addressing the committee
this will reduce background noises and
avoid any unintentional disturbances
the meeting is being hosted remotely
streamed live
and recorded and by being present in the
meeting you are giving your consent to
being recorded
members and officers during each item
please use the hands up function of the
meeting to indicate if you wish to speak
and i will invite you to speak at the
appropriate time
members are reminded that apart from
indicating points of order
or that you have to leave the meeting
the chat function should not be used for
questions or any other purpose
uh when speaking and referring to the
agenda papers please ensure you
reference a page or paragraph
paragraph number and keep your
contributions as clear and concise as
possible
when invited to speak please ensure you
turn on your microphone
and video if possible we now
keep our video on all the time but
obviously some people do have
connection with issues in which case
just let us know in the chat
if you have to switch it if your video
dies on you or you have to switch it off
now may ask officers taking part in the
meeting to introduce themselves starting
with mr geller
good morning everyone uh damian geller
lead specialist
community thank you thank you mr winter
you're meeting hello there my name is
daniel winter
i um chelmsford city council malden and
district council licensing
officer thank you mr quote
simon quelch a legal advisor thank you
and miss bird good morning chairman good
morning members tara bird community
services officer thank you
thank you any other officers present
involved in the meeting has distinct
from support
okay before i call on the clerk to take
a role of committee members
can i ask those counsellors in
attendance to introduce themselves
please i know we have councillor stilts
so could you introduce good morning
councillor
um in attendance thank you
who else council morris
good morning on this glorious day
council morris is uh
lurking okay thank you anybody else
don't think so right okay moving on
so could you please carry out the roll
call of members to confirm those who are
pregnant oh yes chairman members if you
could just indicate your present when i
call your name please
starting with counselor helm
present thank you very much casamays
yeah good morning
good morning
good morning present thank you and mrs
thompson
i am thank you chairman uh the next
answer is apologies for absence but uh
we have none can you confirm that please
tara
yes tommy that's correct got no apology
right item four on the agenda is
disclosure of interest to disclose the
existence
and nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interests other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regard to paragraphs six
to eight inclusive of the code of
conduct for members
members are reminded that they're also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware
and should the need arise throughout the
meeting if any member has an interest to
declare please use the hands up function
now to indicate and i will invite you to
speak
i'm not seeing any hands um can i just
confirm that reviews but
you will not either i know kevin i'm not
no
excellent thank you right so we move on
to the
item five exclusion of the public and
press so i'd
move that under section 100a brackets
for the local government at 1972
the public be excluded from the meeting
for the following item of business
on the grounds that involves the likely
disclosure of exempt information as
designed
as defined in paragraphs one and two of
part one of schedule 12a to the act
and that this satisfies the public
interest test if any member wishes to
second that motion please
unmute your microphone and state your
name now
[Music]
has spoken which i presume we have um
can we agree that by
ascent
agreed agree anyone against
right we have agreed that um by consent
and therefore we will just have a very
brief course while the live streaming is
stopped and um
you